freer to memorize that we're to do our
job and then we cares we did our job we
did our job we memorize the line what
brings you so close I'm going to that
destination wedding to keep it so we're
just the people you don't know how to
stick you might as well just stick us
together I don't want to be a person you
don't know where to stick so this is
your fourth film together
third time playing love interests and
this friendship that you guys have is
what 25 plus you know it's over 30 so
tell me about shooting this one cuz how
did you guys get that fast-talking
clipdown lots of work yeah I mean
there's a lot of energy in the script
and the characters have a lot of energy
to my brother's wedding I don't like my
brother I don't like my mother
I really like but I'm Beth but I'm a
good son I'm a good I'm here to do it
because I have to do it so I'm kind of
hard a good guy
I understand how even after Keith did
what he did to you can possibly still be
mooning over her because you're a monkey
who doesn't understand the human
condition having met you I understand
why it's a condition you were fiancee to
my brother but then you yeah I think I
have no reason you soon together and
being thrown together we just start
looking out at the world and then
sharing ourselves with each other yeah
and then we're kind of you know it's a
meet-cute but a weird meet you yeah yeah
I'm sorry what was that you just took a
step forward there again yeah you did
you know you did
and what's funny is there's no way you
can board first because the only way you
the board first is to be a special name
do you have a special need yes I need to
be over there tell me about the
rehearsal process well we really have it
really because I sort of saw this as a
play in that sense and and but we didn't
get to have that thing you have in the
theatre where you have months and months
rehearsal but but we did as much as we
could and I think there must have been
an aspect of terror because there wasn't
a lot of coverage so it was like I mean
it was bigger than it usually is in that
sense but it was still just doing our
job even though we woke up in the
morning with the bed at night called
each other all of the time every spare
moment running lines totally terrified
having fun we have these wonderful
characters that we get to play I know
okay so tell me about the texting back
and forth were you trying to make sure
that you want ahead on the learning like
I've got I'm coming over right now yes
she believes there's someone for
everybody close I believe that there's
nobody for anyone
have you guys had any horror stories
about weddings well I mean I had one set
of wedding that I was went to with a
friend of mine in France and I couldn't
find it yeah Wow okay free technology
GPS stuff so just got lost you know what
can find it sucked I went to their home
country home and waited in the party or
anything I couldn't find driver like
they should be sorry
that's what I would be like no my
pajamas why would you they're so
alluring
what is that think it's a Melman lawyer
could it be a Jaguar what difference
does it make mm-hmm cougar maybe Jesus
course the two of you guys both have so
many like iconic roles what is your
favorite of each others it's a it's so
hard
river's edge Scanner Darkly going back
prince of pennsylvania and then
obviously billet ed those movies were
very deep movies for me I love love love
love those movies I love that Henry's
Henry's crying crying you know matrix
too and I know it like probably
everyone's come on
obviously the Private Idaho yes I am
obviously that one yeah okay what about
you um yeah it's almost like the
different angles of unknown you know
because there's such an inferior telogen
sand humour and dryness and world-weary
and then you also have the kind of
energy or the lightness that you kind of
go through and like an eel juice where
there's just kind of a whimsy to your
performing but then you also have that
kind of contained thing that's in
Dracula you had that level Dracula age
of innocence idea it just turned 30 I
know and I would love to sit and talk
about that sequel and maybe the villain
Ted sequel but I only have one question
left so you have stranger things you
have John wick sorry coming out and you
guys aren't gonna tell me anything about
it but can you make up something for
John wick three and can you make up
something for stranger things and I'll
just pretend that they're real spoiler I
said even if we did that weekend